♪ ♪ ♪
- L'automne dernier, Romane
Angers-Laurin a appris, bien
maréré elle, les limites
de l'accessibilité à
l'avortement en Gaspésie.
Et ce, même si elle réside
à Gaspé, la plus importante
ville de la péninsule.
ROMANE ANGERS-LAURIN
- J'ai pris un test de grossesse
positif, ps s moi, je pensais
que ça faisait... peut-être 2-3
semaines, même pas un mois que
j'étais enceinte, parce que
je n'ai jamais arrêté d'avoir
mes règles.
- Pourtant, l'échographie
planifiée avant son avortement
révèle qu'elle est enceinte
depuis 4 mois.
- L'avortement, à Gaspé, est
accessible juste avant
12 semaines de grossesse. Alors
moi, j'ai dû aller à l'extérieur
de Gaspé.
- Bien que le  territoire
gaspésien s'étende sur plus
de 800 kilomètres de côte,
seul l'hôpital de Gaspé offre
l'avortement chirurgical et
le service n'est même pas offert
jusqu'à la fin du premier
trimestre de grossesse.
CONNIE JACQUES, pdg adjointe
CISSS de la Gaspésie
- C'est offert à Gaspé. À la
clinique de planning de Gaspé,
jusqàà 12 semaines et 6 jours,
on est capable de faire
l'intervention à Gaspé comme
tel. Ça prend une certaine
expertise et avec nos petits
volumes, Gaspé est le centre
de référence pour l'ensemble
du territoire.
- L'option la plus proche pour
Romane était donc se rendre
à l'hôpital de Rimouski,
un voyage de 9 heures aller-
retour. Elle a plutôt choisi
d'aller à Québec, ce qui
représente 16 heures de route
au total.
- J'avais de la famille là-bas,
plus de support.
- Mais même les Gaspésiennes qui
ont la possibilité de se faireae
parcourent souvent des centaines
de kilomètres. Celles qui
résident à l'ouest de la région
doivent rouler entre 3 et 5
heures pour se rendre à Gaspé.
Ce n'est pas pour rien que
l'endroit est surnommé "le bout
du monde".
♪ ♪ ♪
- Aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine,
malgré une population six fois
plus petite qu'en Gaspésie,
l'avortement chirurgical est
assuré jusqu'à 15 semaines et 6
jours de grossesse, après quoi
les femmes doivent prendre
l'avion pour se faire avorter
à Québec, une réalité qui
s'applique à de nombreux autres
soins de santé spécialisés qui
ne sont pas offerts dans
l'archipel.
Dr SERGE GRAVEL, dir., services
hospitaliers, CISSS des Îles
- Quand les services ne sont pas
donnés, c'est facile qu'ils
les aient dans la capitale
nationale ou ailleurs. J'ai
des gens qui vont à Montréal
pour des examens chez
des spécialistes. J'en ai
d'autres qui vont... beaucoup
à Québec.
- La distance, c'est notre plus
gros enjeu en Gaspésie et
aux Îles.
- La Table de concertation des
groupes de femmes Gaspésie-Îles-
de-la-Madeleine est d'avis que
toutes les femmes n'ont pas
un accès égal à l'avortement.
Encore faut-il qu'elles aien
les moyens de se déplacer, car
les remboursements offerts
par l'État ne couvrent souvent
qu'en partie les coûts réels
d'un déplacement.
LÉA BLOUIN-RODRIGUE, agente,
santé des femmes, TCGF-GÎM
- Il va vraiment y avoir
cecet enjeu-là de distance
à parcourir, donc des frais
de déplacement, peut-être
prendre congé au travail,
également peut-être
de l'hébergement. L'accès n'est
pas le même pour chacune,
t'sais, quand on a les moyens
de se déplacer, c'est plus
simple, mais parfois ce n'est
vraiment pas le cas pour toutes.
- Le CISSS de la Gaspésie mise
sur la pilule abortive pour
améliorer l'accès à l'avortement
sur le territoire, et non
sur l'implantation du service
chirurgical dans d'autres
hôpitaux.
CONNIE JACQUES, pdg adjointe
CISSS de la Gaspésie
DeDepuis 2018, on travaille
plutôt à implanter un autre type
d'avortement, l'avortement
inférieur de 9 semaines, donc
l'avortement par médicaments.
Et c'est plus cette option-là,
en fin de compte, qu'on
travaille à l'heure actlllle
pour s'assurer que c'est bien
ancré sur l'ensemble
du territoire.
- Le Collège des médecins
encadre toutefois la
prescription de pilule abortive
de façon plus sévère qu'ailleurs
au Canada.ntntre 45 et 65
avortements ont lieu chaque
année en Gaspésie; moins de 20%
d'entre eux sont faits par
médicaments.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais au-delà de l'accessibilité
géographique, un autre obstacle
se dresse devant les
Gaspésiennes et Madeliniennes
qui souhaitent interrompre
leleur grossesse : obtenir
le service dans l'anonymat.
JOCELYNE LANDRY, agente,
Regroupement, La Sentin'Elles
- Alors, dans un contexte
insulaire, c'est sûr que...
peut-être que les difficultés
sont amplifiées parce que, comme
on est dans un petit milieu,
juste le fait de devoir
réfléchir à ça et peut-être
de partager aussi sa réflexion,
ça ouvre la porte à bien
des peurs, entre autres,
cellese la confidentialité,
celle aussi du jugement,
de la stigmatisation aussi.
- On est dans un petit milieu.
Au niveau de la confidentialité,
certaines personnes peuvent
avoir des appréhensions. Donc,
il y en a qui vont préférer se
déplacer pour éviter de croiser
peut-être quelqu'un qu'on
connaît.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Romane Angers-Laurin espère
que les tabous entourant
l'avortement vont tomber, et que
les femmes n'auront plus à se
cacher pour recourir à
ce service, car la route
à emprunter pour interrompre
sa grossesse est déjà assez
éprouvante.
- Ça peut être difficile parce
que... t'sais, on est quand même
loin de toute, là. Même Rimouski
c'est loin. Fait que... pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas...ueue
sa famille est à Gaspé,
quelqu'un qui n'a pas
de transport nécessairement,
ça peut être vraiment difficile
paparce que c'est quelque chose
quand même assez "rough" que
tu vis. Fait que, c'est le fun
d'avoir du monde autour de toi.
- Malgré la distance parcourue,
Romane a pu se faire avorter
comme elle le désirait, sans
honte ni secret, entourée de
sa famille, mais elle sait que
toutes les femmes n'ont pas
cette option.
Ici Isabelle Laro,,
Radio-Canada, Gaspé.